so how many how many days altogether
what was the campaign that you planned
the campaign was it was 30 well it's at
33 days but it was more like thirty two
and a half um we launched on a Sunday
afternoon um the campaign ads on friday
at 9pm so 32 days and some change and so
and now we're down to the final six days
yep so so take me and take me into like
a typical day you know in the crowd
funny because it sounds like you guys
are continuing to work full-time and yet
here you are trying to raise a large sum
of money on top of it what's a typical
crowdfunding day life for you so I think
typically you know in the morning before
before we leave for work well um you
know check email um check online that
kind of thing when i put sweet yeah
let's get all the tweet so she'll
schedule before she leaves work oh I'll
get to work um do some work and then set
aside talk time to UM go online schedule
some tweets try to do some follow-up to
those and I have to do it before i leave
for work or the night before because i
have a firewall I can't get through so I
can't access facebook I can't get to
Twitter and once i'm at work so I'm
going to do it all Oh through HootSuite
so I can you know have it set up ahead
of time I'm some cut off the whole time
and i'll just try to be as active as I
can um hope said I don't get pulled into
something from my day job during the day
sometimes I'll look up and realize that
a couple hours have passed by and and
you know I haven't done it an active at
all all in in the campaign so that
that's during the day and then I think I
think every couple days we sort of like
reevaluate where we are too so you know
we had a schedule going into it's like
okay this is what we're going to
accomplish and then like you know when
you're not able to meet certain things
or something gets puss ort of said like
okay well how important is that one
thing and do we need to get that done
tonight and that kind of thing um but
yeah I mean he's been staying up like
till three or four and a lot of time
when i'll be getting up because i won't
have finished what i needed to do the
night before so you know when i stayed
up on like twitter for a while then it
was like twelve o'clock and i didn't
have my stuff ready for the next day so
you know going to bed waking up that
early plentywood it's been a handoff up
early no let me going to bed really late
her or waking up really early and then
um getting a little bit of sleep and
then then had to work and then we
carpool to work um which is nice because
then we can catch up lamb plan okay plan
for that night what we're going to do do
do we need to do right up do we need to
reach out tomorrow send some emails what
exactly we're doing that night we'll
plan on the drive home and I mean
knowing you two I mean own you know I we
know that you've been involved in the
filmmaking community for a long time now
you know you've been supported with many
other crowdfunding campaigns so it's not
like you're just diving in not knowing
anything but even with that I mean sort
of like what were your expectations
before the launch they were real
expectations coming into this I think
you know we talked about this recently
we're like we I don't think that we
underestimated how much work was
involved i think that partly understood
and from talking to other filmmakers and
other people who have done it you're
like we knew how completely overwhelming
it would be but even so it's still even
more overwhelming than you think even
knowing that but aside from that I mean
for me I think I i overestimated how
much i could physically chu Ming li get
done like I mean it's not like yeah you
can try to fill every second in every
moment but like at some point you do
have to go to sleep at some point you do
have to eat I think you have to go to
bed like you have to like give you
little things in your life that like
like that takes time like yeah I may
just be like 10 minutes but there are
things that you you have to give and
it's like you can't cram all of your
parts of your life into every literal
second every single minute yeah and I
think that was the toughest part because
we did know how incredibly hard it was
going to be but there's a big difference
between actually being in it and and
knowing
and I think the frustrating thing has
been that we just haven't we haven't had
the man-hours to do what we needed we
knew there was a certain threshold of
effort that needed to be put in it and
you know we had to just kind of at
certain point just watch that go by
because you know the Sun was coming up
literally
you